[Music]
thank you thanks for having me so today
I'm going to talk about online learning
I'm going to try to explain to you why
it's good for you why you need it why
but before doing all that I mean before
showing the library and why I'm going to
blog I'm gonna tell you why I'm gonna
tell you about bachelor learning and I'm
gonna tell you some pain points that you
probably all know about but we always
forget to I mean we think we take it for
granted
that's training so bachelor learning is
what you all know most of you when you
do much when you do a machine learning
is your data when you think of your data
you think of a big data firm so you have
like a big X a big Y and you learn
everything at the same time and then
depends on your applications your use
case you're going to save the model and
yeah and you're going to save the model
and then you're going to load there and
and use it okay so in production it
depends I mean it's not like a clear-cut
thing like we all know we have
scikit-learn or chemists but when it
comes to production I don't think
everything's as crystal clear as it
shouldn't be so typically you have your
data somewhere you're going to train the
model and then you're going to store it
and then when necessary maybe depends if
you need to do things in live or not
you're going to load it and make do
predictions so I don't know if everyone
like agrees with this maybe not but you
can tell me afterwards but this is how I
perceive it but at least I'm I'm a PhD
student so I'm not sure I've done some
internships but maybe that life is not
like this but I know this maps learning
is hard I have never seen people agree
on this I've never seen people say oh
it's so easy to put machine learning
production it is a hard thing to do I
think we need a lot of people with many
degrees and master's PhD and no one has
like a really clean solution to this
year I think and my solution is not it's
not the best but it's like a different a
shift at least so some problems of batch
learning so we all agree with this you
have to retrain your model new data
comes in every week you have to retrain
your model and this is like a big thing
you always do when you
when you do this there's more data and
normally need more and more and more
computer power okay big data models are
static so a model that you've trained
this week maybe next week it doesn't
work because new features because
because because for many reasons
basically but models there is a drift
models learn data from a certain point
in time and then it's their static they
can't learn on their own what's
happening so features this is a bit more
subtle the features that you develop
locally might not be available in real
time what I mean by this is that you
think that you found this great feature
oh wait
what's yeah no they're not yeah I see
people with they're like okay so I'll go
quick okay yeah this is you must always
this way they were talking what's he
talking about
okay yeah yeah it's about learning this
is what you do you okay you learn you
their production yeah it makes more
sense right we'll get this I'll get them
hang them right so for me batch learning
is hard right so this is why I think it
feels like it's like putting a square
peg in a round hole right it just
doesn't feel right at least recyclate
learn and many so models have to be
retrained we agree more and more
computer power models are static and
they lot faster than bananas because
bananas rot first and depends and
features that you so we here some
features that you developed locally
might not be available so sometimes
features that you think are good just
don't work right because it turns out
that in real time they're just not
available you don't know so and just
like we need to poo we to used to
banging our heads and we always just
take things for granted we don't think
out of the box and we just say well I'm
not good enough or
but you don't really think about your
the approach will take maybe that the
approach is wrong so online learning so
I'm going to tell you about online
knowing them so now I'm learning it's
simple it's just the data is available
one by one and your model learns one
instance hard time so everything changes
and things like the number of features
dynamic could be three could be ten it's
all dynamic the number of classes if
you're doing classification don't know
it I do at the start I don't know
anything okay I do know that I'm doing
regression I do know that I'm doing
binary classification multi class but
there's a lot of things I just don't
assume so different name same thing
because I think naming is important you
can call it online learning you can call
it incremental learning called a
sequential out of course it's the same
thing it's always learning one instance
our time and the applications are many
maybe this flights they've been at the
end but just to realize everything
basically with data coming in everything
with live data so you train your model
there's already new data that's the kind
of applications that we were hinting at
okay so not cargo not I have a train and
I have a test it's really it's really
different from that and it's more
realistic more real-life okay so this is
what looks like in a nutshell so so it's
your data comes in and online nothing I
have to say one thing is that this guide
the food you don't know where it's going
but it you can you can discard it right
okay you don't have to store the data
which is really really nice to have so
but why do we all do much learning well
I don't do philosophy but I think for
many reasons and maybe the biggest
reason is not start it's the library
availability like we have cycle you say
oh I have a hammer everything's a nail
so maybe it's because you know
literature and the world before there
was not this much data maybe that we're
just trying to well remove that the maps
and the code has adapted fast enough so
we just all used to you know thinking of
data is like one big block there is a
block it's a stream and so for this we
created a library me and some friends
over here called cream so cream because
it comes from incremental
and the IHI you'll see it's very
inspired from scikit-learn so if the
same module names etc and so we started
this in mid-january I think I started
and then people some people join me and
we just released version of 0.01 this
Wednesday so I'm going to tell you about
it so just quickly what we how we see
data we see as so one instance at time
so features a dictionary and so the keys
are the names of the features and the
values can be anything so you may be
know that in a dictionary you don't have
to it's not statically typed it just
have to be numbers it can be dates can
be strings so more fun to use then numpy
maybe because you can use names and you
can have different types etc sometimes
that's a bit of a pain point you know
whoops I could learn anyway I'm not
dissing scikit-learn I'm just trying to
talk about something they're different
but so yeah targets we what you will be
presenting as anything it depends it can
be a string it can be but it's just a
scalar value just a single value
so no array is no it's always just one
value yeah and so streaming data so this
is the start of it we what we do is
there's always going to be a for loop
there's always going to be a loop where
the data is coming it can be a calf cash
stream it can be a CSV file it can be
anything but the data is only one
observation in memory at the time okay
and so here you have the API the first
method which you use it's called fit one
so fit one you give the model
observations yeah but just one and then
a feature and it learns he adapts
updates so you see that things are
completely different right
this could live in an HTTP requests it
could live in the for loop it could live
offline online and most importantly if I
stop training and I can always start
again later okay so very very flexible
they are some down down there are some
problems to this but not many
and so we have fit one we have predict
one also so you give it one dictionary
of features and you get your prediction
okay so what very important is that you
can predict before training and you can
predict after training okay
so we say that training and testing our
prediction are interleaved is one after
the other
okay so don't do the after don't need it
before
so after don't train and then predict
because then it would be a bit cheating
Billy we have classifiers also so
predict probability one predict Polly
one Transformers transform one obviously
and some performance for example here I
have my logistic regression and I have a
metric accuracy well of course it's
simple to update it you just say is my
prediction correct okay so we have a
matrix model and in the metrics model
you have matches that there's an update
method okay so I what happens is that
I'm predicting I saw the out of so
before seeing the day before sin the Y I
predict for X what am I saying is it is
it like a class is this value regression
and then I can update my metric and then
I can update my model etc and I can
print my metric if I want and so here
you have composition so I'm just giving
a few examples but this documentation
afterwards you'll see
but yeah so if you want to build a
pipeline so you want to scale your data
and you want to do a logistic regression
well turns out you can do that online
and so here you have the pipe operator
this is kind of fun it's saying I do a
pipeline okay so in cycle don't you say
pipeline you can do that in cream too
but you can also do this we did a fancy
operator where you can just use the pipe
operator so fun to work over these are
the models that are at the moment is 20
of them and hopefully not more comic
it's too much code but yes so you
recognize a lot of symptoms like it
learned maybe maybe some fun things that
we have done not in scikit-learn that
because we have the flexibility to work
of it as recommendation so we also
working on making online recommenders so
maybe some of you know of supplies the
library - the recommendation well it
turns out that surprise the algorithm
has videogum
you can do online so again we can do
that too
we also have decision trees online
that's really fun and the powerful
so I don't know if you know about them
but these things exist fine so I'm just
going to show you some stats examples
not too much very nothing but for
example say you want to compute the mean
the mean of some data right so what you
would typically do as a human or if
numpy is you'd sum all the values and
divide by the number of values right but
that's assuming you have all the data at
the same time what turns out is an exact
algorithm that works online and you just
use the simple formula and you can
update your min so here you have in
cream we have like a stats module where
you can have variance etc many things
and you have this update type line
update get update get so so is the date
comes in I update and then I get easy
right and there's a formula for variance
too so this is called well photographer
it exists for skew exist for kurtosis so
and they exact right there's not enough
proximation it's really exact and it
works and it's nice and it's not using
any memory and it's live and you can do
many things ok so one thing you can do
is standard scaling like this was me
because this is the first algorithm
decoding cream I was like hang on okay
what can I do now we online because if
you can do this you can do many things
right so this is simple you just compute
the mean and the variance online and
then every observation that comes in
your scaler okay so you can and after
like 30 values it's the same as if you
use scikit-learn it's exactly the same
it just becomes the same because looks
like it learned you would have computed
the min on all the data and old and the
variance and all the date and then you
would have scaled this is really one by
one so the value the value is going to
get at the end all different but not so
much so it's worth it and we also have
linear regression when we have many
things but linear regression just
quickly so we have this we try to build
like a really flexible API but maybe you
know that there's different algorithms
to find the weights of ran the
regression well we made it so that you
can use different optimizers a bit like
Kharis so in this case I'm using atom
but I can also use FTIL what Google uses
or RMS pop for many things or just plain
simple HDD but yeah this is just I'm
just trying to sell Chromebook there's
some fun things like you
you know you bang I mean because we
created this we try to make it very
flexible and fun and etc the same thing
this is a very cool one so we wrote a
user guide as like a section in our user
guide on this but the intercept of our
linear regression we don't optimize it
with the optimizer we actually maintain
a running statistics so for example we
make the end the intercept of our model
is the mean okay but it's the learning
mean that I just showed you so we can go
a bit further with this and I won't show
you but you can see online there's we
can use the mean on the last X values so
say you can use the mean on the last 12
days ok so your mean is then adapting to
drift ok let's change in and for time
series this is very cool so yeah we've
online models we have some some
flexibility so yeah here we use rolling
mean with 42 values so it just use the
mean on the last 42 values the model so
same you can do goodbyes online so you
want to group by a key and you want to
calculate a mean or a sum or something
so in here we have some places and we
have revenue and we want to compute the
mean well we have this this class in the
feature extraction module where you
specify a play what the key so I'm going
to go by on place and then I'm going to
compute a statistic on the revenue I'm
going to compute the mean and it just is
print a pencil so this is all exact to
and it's done online bagging to I won't
spend too much time on this but the idea
is that boosting bagging there are
techniques to do this online the
intuition of it basically is that when
you're doing back in each observation it
follows a certain distribution the
number of time we get can't get picked
by a model and that distribution you can
show that it follows a Poisson
distribution so very simply the code is
quite simple when you're doing this it
should when you're learning online so
you have one feature coming in and one
set of features in one target well for
each estimator so you're doing bagging
so it means you have like 30 models for
each model well you pick a number a
personal number right a number that
comes from a Poisson distribution and
you're going to train the model on that
data point what
this many times and it works and for
predicting you're just going to make
every model predict and you're going to
say compute the mean of all the
predictions yeah so yeah an example so
this is not online yet because I'm poor
but there's a we what we did is we took
League of Legend games and we try to
forecast the this is not moving though
oh yeah yes you know sorry okay so I
don't know what's going on but so yeah
we try to take a League of Legend games
okay and we try to predict the duration
of these games so what happens is that
you have a league of Legends game that
starts and you want to predict the
duration and then when the game ends you
know the true duration so then you can
update your model so if you want to do
this with Bachelor you would have waited
a month have a month of data train your
model user and then update but you do
every week every month this is all
online so you predict and then you train
but all interleaves all online so
there's no training phase so on the fly
so this I'll show you quickly some code
but it's quite simple how it works and
the idea is that online learning because
you don't have to Train offline is much
simpler to print for into production so
here you have some games so wait so you
predict the duration and then the game
ends and it says how by how much you're
wrong etc but the games really so users
can put a game ID in and it's going to
make the prediction and then it's going
to wait for the game to end and pull and
wait for the game to end and then update
the model and it all works online and
here you have the architecture quickly
so we have random polling so we're going
to check for random games and then we're
going to have some some user requests
and people going to pick a game and then
so this is just a jank a very simple
django app the match starts we made the
prediction we store the features until
the game ends and then when the game
ends well the model can update and and
then we can just show that to the user
so here you have some jungle code very
so this is to like exemplify how simple
is to put this in place so the old
machine running thing that works
so you'll we
have a simple class with where we're
going to store the estimator so really
the the class that's doing the
prediction and the learning in as a pic
object okay so we're going to work also
on doing it in Jason but for the moment
we just do in pickle and then you can
use this you can just load in real time
and then and then do the prediction but
and also the training so for predict and
here is you just load you get the
features online so you just go to buy it
is the company that handles and you have
legends you get your features you get
all you but the features are calculated
on the fly by claim does this it's not
something that you do offline all this
is done online and then the model you
load it okay and since this is an HTTP
request you do the prediction and that's
it and then for training is the same
thing the game ends we get access to a
new property called true duration so
it's the number of seconds that the game
lasted and then we're going to use this
to update the model so we fit and we
take the raw information about the game
so what country is a five versus five
game what champions are playing etc and
then we have the true duration and
that's it we train the model so predict
train predict train and then for
calculators and performance well you
could use a metric rack I showed you
before but here we just use an SQL query
so with django so you just take the all
the predictions and then you just can
compute an average if you want so this
is just a fancy django code to do that
it's just basically an average duration
okay so this was really simple to put in
place cream is we coded it and you know
we work on it but this the League of
Legends app took me literally a weekend
because and the hardest was not the
machine running thought it was really
just the web thought but the fit predict
things I show you that's all there is to
it there's no fancy spark going on
there's no fancy offline handing it over
handing over it's just it just works
online and that's really simple to do so
the benefits are that you don't have to
schedule training as I said that already
and this is really easy to debug a
monitor because when you're training
offline or whatever you can do the for
loop and then you know straightaway if
you if you want gone now although it's
and you don't have to like there's no
RAM crashing or you have too much data
or
from that it's really when you're
training during the fit doing the fit
ones you already have
some estimate of your ever you don't
have to fit and then then wait and then
do the validation it's all online
so it's this way time in it's hard to
sell this to people because you really
have to change the mindset here it's
really changing the idea of not having
all your data but just having it come as
a stream and we think also it's more fun
to code with ready source more fun to
develop with and so yeah decision trees
I mentioned we have them there in the
library but they're just not as they
need some polishing to make sure that
the performance is okay
but there's things called hefting trees
and there's Mondrian trees but these are
like approximations to the real decision
trees you're used to the cart but they
work they after so many ten thousands of
examples they do converge to the same
thing as if you did a batch wise but
it's always the fit one predict one API
it's always one of features and one
target and and yeah we know that some
people have joined me we're going we're
going to work on a lot of things but the
idea is to keep it simple and nice and
the same way that scikit-learn is nice
for bachelor learning we want to try to
make it fun to use so here you have some
links so also if you want to help or
contribute we not just coding but also
if you just want to try this maybe at
your company or so on some problem feel
free to like get in touch and tell us
like what's difficult how you how this
doesn't integrate with you maybe have
some issues or why you could not use
this I mean I'm really interested why
okay maybe that the performance is
slightly lesser but it really is close
to batch learning but apart from the
performance why would this not be better
than Bachelor learning I'm really
interested to know why because I do
think that this makes things much easier
so yeah I'm done so thanks for listening
and questions
[Applause]